hey I like this I'm like wow let
jewelry.what ashton kutcher on Monday
night's Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
spilling on his new stache
I never intended to have this I don't
think I look good with it but I'm
keeping it the actor says it's actually
Adele he reveals that his wife Mila
Kunis is friends with Adele and that she
invited them to her birthday party she
comes the day of the birthday party
she's like listen the theme for the
birthday party is 1970s New Year's and
I'm like who throws the 1970s New Year's
birthday party I'm like we're both on
the 70s show I think we got this okay
yeah ashin explains that while getting
ready the mustache info I'm looking in
the mirror and I've got a beard going
and I'm like oh I'm going 70s - like
it's gonna happen it's cute it's very
sweet but when they got to the bash it
wasn't what he expected we show up and
I'm looking around nobody else is in
1970s anything right and I'm like what
kind of pills the theme for the parties
1930s New Year's and I look like Burt
Reynolds from Boogie Nights
what are you gonna be like I got the
decade wrong I'm just playing it off
like this is how I'm doing it these days
and I'm like what's up jay-z yeah this
is my thing they're people who are
really honestly had your best interest
in mind and are gonna tell you the truth
et has been with Ashton and Mila a ton
over the years they're always honest and
funny what has been your biggest good
mom moment that you were like totally
like hey I'm awesome I rock every night
that we put Wyatt down we high-five each
other and we're like we did it every
single day we kept her alive we're like
she's alive and we're still in love
you